bella tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovo video io sono pari j
oggi finalmente si riparte raga sono
tornato dalle vacanze
lo so che è stato un delirio perché in
molti mi chiedevate pensavate che fosse
morto nonostante l'avessi detto che
andava in vacanza ma alcuni pensavano
fossi morto sono tornato state
tranquilli sono vivo e vi spiegherò poi
tutto nel blog perché qua sono è un
casino non essendo a casa non ho potuto
vedere che cosa è uscito e mi avete
consigliato diverse cose tra i quali
pare poi vedrete tra i quali c'era anche
questo in viola che tra quelli usciti in
queste settimane mi sembra il migliore
che è the train crisi lega direi di
iniziare subito non mi soffermo iniziamo
andiamo su game
non so che cos'è sta roba ma me l'avete
consigliati in praticamente tutti è un
indie horror sembra essere fatto coi
contro maroni quindi direi di iniziare
allora la partenza è sempre questa come
minchia ci siamo arrivati qui non si sa
va bene andiamo avanti
c'è una legge una legge chiara che è
tutto il russo non si capisce un cazzo
però vabbè ci ton qua quindi ragazzi nel
caso sappiamo tutti cosa fare
l'ambientazione fantastica vi giuro mi
sembra di giocare a mandarsi inferno
è alle porte sia un perfetto la ragazza
portare un pò più stronzo 6 gol ragazzi
sta succedendo si va meno io vado avanti
su questa chi è questa che c'e l'ombra
di una bambina non so dove sta puntando
ritmi tv ho capito lo so la voce le
tracce un citofono
[Musica]
questa deve essere dubstep russa carina
significa piacere che è perfetto lì è il
paradiso cos'è sta roba perché
illuminatissimo bene ci siamo siamo i
ragazzi siamo entrambi in silent hill
non lo so c'è una legge assurda e vabbè
animava giorno c'è qualcuno a qui ho
trovato un triciclo sembra quello di
psycho non importa ragazzi andiamo
avanti
ci sono delle bambolina quanto [ __ ]
ragazzi ora il masso che le bambine
giocassero con le barbie non crosta roba
comunque va bene spero che tu di odio
cos'è cos'è che è successo dove cazzo
sia 1990 siamo un po tornati indietro
nel tempo non lo so cos'è un flash back
up risto porta un inizio nel semi è già
aperta devi solo tirarci un calcio
niente lav e giochiamo quella palla
questo mi pare ci sono delle valigie
ragazzi non ho capito lo scopo di sto
gioco si sa c'è il triciclo che bello
ragazzo diventa odio e il costo di
inception
mi fa molto piacere adesso se permettete
io me ne vado perché non so che cosa ci
sto a fare qui si è aperta la porta non
benissimo non so cosa sto facendo una
camusso
ok preso di nuovo tutto ok perfetto
siamo tornati nel treno era un flashback
di qualcosa che non so bene cosa vabbè
andiamo avanti e inizio
ragazzi guarda
lo so che qashqai salve lei è qui da
quanto no io mi sono svegliato prima non
voglio toccarti giocattoli stai
tranquillo che cos'è ragazzi questo era
il quanto macabro devo dirlo vabbè dove
siamo e siamo al seno di musica momento
c'è di nuovo il bambino fu merda c'è un
bambino ragazzi cè un bambino in fondo
io non so che cosa devo fare
prima le signore sempre che tu sia una
signora va bè ragazzi l'arciere sono
toni j
cos'è lega
devo chiudere le porte dall'interno che
ai ragazzi più ci provo a perfetto fatto
tutto da solo meglio così così io mi
devo sbattere a cercare le cose perfetto
suo ventre all 8 poi uscire per chi sono
questi per un attimo perché la youtube e
si potesse uscire i ragazzi è la porta è
chiusa mi dispiace non me la apro
ragazzi mi dispiace ma ho chiuso la
porta allora lo vedete questo lo vedete
1 e 2 voti stranzi non entrerete
evidente perché a risvegliare un treno
da solo lo farebbe soltanto un pazzo e
vi sono anche rotto ai carissimi amici
dobbiamo andare avanti sarò un casino
direi di andare avanti non so che cosa
che cos'è sta porta si apre perché c'è
una porta normale in treno non lo so ma
ben hibon da un altro flash back lagane
anche in più tifosi sono buddisti
flashback incredibile siamo di nuovo qui
fantastico stavolta si apre la porta
spero di si deve tirarci un calcio non è
difficile
no non si apre da seguito ragazzi questo
è il booker fa prima che gli ha coperto
poi dovere
ieri c'era dov'è il mio voto
ringrazi smettetela di picchiarli raga è
una cosa molto brutta non la sa ma non
posso dare una mano perchè non si apre
la porta comunque voyeurismo vodka
questo blog si è sbloccato qualcosa bene
siamo usciti grazie alla potenza del
modica fa questo ed altro
ci sono mica i vicini non lo so ragazzi
c'è qualcuno che lì dentro si sta
picchiando c'è un flash back court
siamo tornati dovevamo prima di sicuro
662 cosa non lo so c'è qualcuno perché
se c'è gente non ci posso credere
ho trovato vodka ragazzi c'è gente
senti buon uomo non so chi c'è dietro
marcia vodka è mica sa dirmi corso no
ragazzi e brutta situazione
chi ha scoraggiato sei stato tu il
brutto bambino c'è la mamma deve tenerli
d'occhio bella [ __ ] la mamma tra l'altro
ragazzi non so che cosa sto facendo per
chi sto parlando in rosso non lo so
ragazzi e ragazze oddio è il treno dello
stupro ai 86 un televisore cambiate
canale è fatto e qualcosa io torni
indietro grazie sei molto bello sono
diventati tutti delle marionette
bellissimi
tu sei veramente figo cela il piccolo
non importa andiamo avanti ragazzi è una
brutta situazione ea chi sono quelli ok
e stimolanti teste volanti scuola live
action
the nightmare fantasy
questa roba ok regali chase picchiato
tutto ho buttato giù il monito
fantastico non so se si vede spero di sé
bene dovremo ripartire lo sono morto da
pagarsi in queste situazioni è bene
mantenere la calma e non perdere la
testa
ok e non era proprio l'esempio tanto va
bene assolutamente corni maledetto
stronzo non tocchi gare
cos'è sta roba così foucher e chi sono
sti due levatevi da il cazzo subito c'è
una sciamana l'itis transito anni te
vieni qua dove vai vieni qua non parlano
ancora fatto fuori campo lutto stronzo
se vieni stato viene dov'è
raga ho fatto gli uccisi tutti bene
cioè ho trovato nate ricordate il mio
consiglio di prima nelle belle
situazioni bisogna mantenere la calma e
non perdere la testa prenditela ok era
pessima come cosa ma non importa
martello se devo essere sincera me lo
porterei anche dietro volentieri
perfetto che si è mosso tizio non lo so
perché
muoviti muoviti monte arrivo ragazzi mi
sento il dottor frankenstein perfetto
sei veramente pico c'è la posa d'abruzzo
se sei veramente un figo della madonna
vada avanti ragazzi il suo gioco sta
alimentando assurdo man mano che vado
avanti
ho capito perché me lo avete consigliato
un disastro un altro flash back perfetto
allora ragazzi lo vedo già qualcuno non
sono ancora rinvenuto per bene e già
vedo un tizio in fondo che non mi piace
ai ragazzi e sono appena sceso dal
paradiso giusto per darvi una mano chi è
questo che suonano e la mia chitarra e
stanotte ho addosso suonare meglio io
dammela ragazzi queste skrillex c'è una
cosa incredibile va bene anzi lo shuttle
che vedi che sono buono ti ha lasciato
gli speech e va beh sì che sta facendo i
due non lo so ok perfetto stanno facendo
cose sconce nella metropolitana perché
no stanno litigando cos'è non la
picchiare vedi tela come brutto stronzo
che perfetto d'ora una lezione a questo
bellimbusto se sono colmi j
sono l'allievo di lambach si farà un
culo così vai così se il mio blog che è
meglio del tuo mac
ok perfetto è si vede che è non adesso
mi rialzo state tranquilli e soltanto no
maledizione quella era il primo round
state tranquilli
è diventato tutto bianco non so che è
successa per te sintomatico
oddio che succede ragazzi sta succede
così dove siamo
c'è una scia di sangue perfetto tra già
non vedo nulla
portarsi che casino cioè l'audio è
altissimo vabbè non importa mi sto
stordendo le orecchie che cazzo dio cioè
passato un bambino bene il sangue di per
tizio che mi ha sfidato prima se gli ho
fatto un culo così solo che voi non
avete visto bene allora e dobbiamo
dobbiamo andare via di qua dove siamo
ragazzi dove si sa cos'è sta roba che
lampeggia pagato e siamo cosetta cosa
che lampeggia ragazzo e stiamo veramente
tutto chiaro on the act perfetto chi è
questo
oddio chieco vuol dire sullo smog
germain e anima avanti ragazzi ios segue
la scia di sangue che promette bene una
pistola
prendi la ok ho votato già un proiettile
non mi chiedete perché non sempre
cisamente doveva andare ci sono due
miliardi di via e non lo so c'è una
porta di questa si aprirà perfetto
nessuno che 1 pistola hanno paura di
usarla maria tempo che non mi segue no
non vi ho già dato a farmi scherzi che
c'è una pistola va bene penso sia carica
ragazzi c è chiusa la porta non so se in
niente chiuso per far vincere
ok perfetto e chiude invece maledetta
stanza se fatta bene
dimmi che carichi ti prego divide
carichi se non sono perfetto ragazzi ha
scaricato la pistola
bene così
non ho più potuto proiettile bene così
veramente ne usati 3 me ne servito uno
fantastico
quindi se trovate per caso una pistola
in posti come questi non fate come me
tenetevi i colpi però in compenso c'è un
ascia magari la prendi no non la
prendere ci sono i proiettili bruyette
non lo sono proiettili va bene
ragazzi io non ho un proiettile prima mi
sentivo un po più sicuro adesso no
aprite se incontro un giorno ci ha mica
dei proiettili io perchè gli ho spiegato
prima e divertente la faccenda se volete
il racconto per niente c'è un tizio che
sembrava lo slider man che mi ha quasi
preso in braccio solo dopo l'inchiesta
c'è il mio dio chi è questo chi è
ragazzi si è white che tra way che trovi
modica ragazzi questa è una rapina per
modica è pieno di test perfetto ragazzi
c'è un tizio a terra make anonymous col
tuo ambulanze devo fare un anonima
chiamata l'ambulanza facendo credere che
non sia stato quello ad uccidere il
tizio nessuno blocco alle porte come le
blocco io è perfetto
che razza di posto è questo non lo so
cazzo avevo le mani in alto
avevo le mani in alto avevo chiuso la
porta come chiamano ha fatto a un
trapassare l'armadietto impossibile cioè
allora se io esco d'asta portato il
teamflash io sono valere buono fermo
maledizione impossibile raga non so come
si fa a far fuori sto tizio era che a
questo episodio concluso qui perché non
so come fuggire da quel tizio quanti
mero nel prossimo comunque sedi dove è
piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche a pagina di facebook e come non i
video trovate una descrizione è la sede
per iscritti iscrivete vende ci
rivediamo in un prossimo vitobello
ragazzi